So, before we talk about this
different kind of models, and
we will talk about a number of them,
let's sort of explore what is new thing
that we need for implementing them.
So, we're obviously, I said, going
beyond discretionary access control.
Well, implementation of this mandatory
access control model is going to require
some new functionality,
some new mechanisms the system
has to now include.
So one of the new things that we're
going to talk about all the time is,
what is called sort of these labels
that we're going to associate.
That's a key new
implementation requirement for
defining these models and for
implementing these models.
But idea is that we're going to see
that both users and resources of
documents are going to have certain
labels attached or associated with them.
And they're going to get used in the way
we make access control decisions.
So what's the purpose of a label that
you want to attach to a document or
associate with a user?
The label is actually going
to tell us how sensitive
certain information may be.
Labels also actually have something
that describes the nature of the data.
What topic,
what area does the data come from?
We talked on payroll as another example,
before.
So labels could also include
sort of a category of
the nature of the data
that we have here.
And that's sort of useful in answering
this question, who needs to know or
needs to have accessed?
If you're in the payroll department,
of course you need access
to payroll information.
Labels with documents,
or data files, or users,
are going to capture something
about the information that's
contained in those documents and
the users who need to access them.
So these labels are actually going to
get manipulated each time access to
an object or document is requested.
So TCB is actually not going to
associate, but it's going to use these
labels associated with user and
the object any time the request is made.
So when I say the labels look right,
of course we have to sort of say,
here's the label for the user, and
here's the label for the document.
Should the user be able to access
this document, to be able to read it?
So we have to sort of relate or
compare the labels,
and we're going to see
results of that comparison.
But you're going to say,
here is user with this label, here
is a document with this other label.
Does the user's level imply that
he can access this document?
So we have to relate, compare,
the labels that we have.
Now exact nature of what the labels look
like, and how we are going to be able to
compare them, and what the result
of the comparison is, well, that's
going to depend on the particular model
or policy that we're going to implement.
We're going to look at several different
examples, and each one of them has
a very different kind of a label,
and how you make use of that label.
A label goes with, not just
the document, but also with a user.
And we'll see examples of those.
So in the Department of Defense,
we're talking about the labels
actually going to include.
For a user,
it'll be their clearance level.
For a document, at what level
the document is classified.
And compartment is this category
that we're talking about.
What kind of information is
contained in this document?
Of course, in the commercial world,
we don't have clearances and
classifications.
So these labels have to look different.
And the concerns are going to
be of a different kind, also.
For example, we may have
conflict-of-interest concern.
So access control must be such that when
somebody has a conflict, they don't get
to access a certain document where a
conflict-of-interest, or COI, may arise.
Similarly, sometimes we may have
separation-of-duty requirements.
The same person can do two different
things, when allowing them to do that
requires a level of trust or potential
for fraud and things like that.
So, the needs would be different
in commercial versus DoD,
or garment DoD intelligence agency.